let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the midas media network
special coverage
of the january 6 select hearing we have
a great show for you tonight we are
going to start an hour early with some
commentary from legal analyst
political commentators and we have a few
others that we want to show you tonight
on the list we have michael cohen
trump's former attorney we have karen
and nipollo from legal af we have lee
mcgowan from the
politics girl podcast and texas paul
might just might even know texas paul we
also have david bender and a few others
that will be joining us
on the broadcast for the first hour
this is a very very very important
hearing it is the first hearing of six
that we will see for the january 6th
select committee on the insurrection
that happened on january 6 2021 after
the election as everyone knows donald
trump
spread the big lie in this country and
why these
hearings are so important to our
democracy is to understand
of why the constitution is such an
important foundation of our democracy
without it
you would not have some of the way of
life that you know
today
your community your school
your state your local government your
county governments if you really think
about it if donald trump was successful
in overturning the election
the free and fair election
that the people decided with their vote
if he really would have been able
with him and the proud boys the oath
keepers
with the lackeys at the department of
justice
and some of the others
that all are key players in the
attempted coup
we would have not had the confidence in
the constitution if he would have been
successful
if he would have been successful
what would have stopped him
from changing anything else in our
democracy what would have stopped him
from taking away medicare what would
have stopped him from taking away
medicaid payments
what would have stopped him to say well
this state constitution
the hell with that
what would have stopped him if we did
not stop him from taking away our vote
because that's what he wanted to do on
that day and i believe that's what we're
gonna find out with these hearings
that not just donald trump but a team
several teams of people
from several different legs
of his apparatus that he was trying to
overthrow our government
speaking of donald trump i want to bring
in someone who knows donald trump very
very well
he was his
former personal attorney this person
actually served prison time
for crimes that donald trump had
committed i would say that's probably
what he's going to say
everyone knows michael cohen
from the hearing where michael cohen
spoke about the payment that was given
to stormy daniels and i want to bring
him in now michael um
i i know i know you know donald
better than some because you have been
so close to him
why do you think these hearings are so
important what
what gives you that sense of why the
america needs to really watch these
hearings look how many times do does the
same person meaning myself or you or
might as touch or anybody else how many
more times do we have to sit there and
talk about just how dangerous donald
trump is as an individual now
interestingly enough tony you talked
about for a second what if donald takes
away your medicare what if donald trump
takes away your medicaid i don't think
you're thinking like donald trump and
yes you're right i do know him better
which is why i was successful two and a
half years ago when i warned the world
and i warned specifically this country
that if donald trump lost the election
that there would never be a peaceful
transfer of power it's not that you know
i have some foresight and i can you know
um and i could predict the future no
it's just that i know the animal that
was sitting in the white house and i
know the way he thinks it's much bigger
than medicare it's much bigger than
medicaid he's looking to take away your
freedoms and yes you are right i will
turn around and say that i went to
prison simply because donald trump
ensured that i went to prison and that's
again i have a second book that's going
to be coming out relatively soon called
the department of injustice and i give
you all the facts and i lay the whole
thing out and i will let each individual
reader decide for themselves but one
thing for certain every single aspect of
that book is backed up by
documentation's true the problem with
donald he's not thinking small he's
talking about your first amendment
rights he's talking about your
reproductive rights and rest assured if
you are a minority if you are a member
of the lgbtq plus community if there is
you know if you are an immigrant and so
on you can rest assured donald doesn't
want you here and he will make your life
miserable the man wants to be an
autocrat plain and simple he wants to be
your fuhrer he wants to be you know your
supreme leader and that's that's all
that donald trump wants at first at
first the whole thing meaning the uh
campaign was supposed to be a joke and
it was supposed to be the greatest
infomercial in the history of united
states politics but that's not where it
ended up somehow this ass clown ends up
winning and lo and behold he brings in
with him the dregs of society and the
goal at the time which was donald's
statement is he wants to rid washington
of the swamp in fact the swamp was
better than the [ __ ] that he ended up
bringing in i mean he brought in a
dumpster right a dumpster fire of
garbage individuals who are all looking
to grift off the you know the country
and some of them did it by dealing with
foreign you know uh countries others did
it simply by just taking advantage of
things even like ppp so you have to
think like donald trump now let me just
answer your question on that then how
important are these hearings these these
hearings in my opinion are not going to
sway
a single individual not one
on whether or not donald trump is or is
not guilty we we who are probably here
on this midas on this midas touch you
know network we know that donald is and
we watch to see the 2300 plus text
messages with mark meadows the emails
the 900 and some individuals that all
testified before the committee we all
know exactly what was going on and we're
able to call it for what it is but then
there's still that group those donald
trump sycophantic followers that no
matter what he does they will never hold
him accountable and it's no different
than the statement that donald trump
made not to me
to everybody when he turned around and
he said i can actually shoot somebody on
fifth avenue and get away with it that's
how the man thinks so what i believe
these hearings will end up doing is very
much like what the mueller report did it
will be a historical document that
people will talk about for a year 2 10
they'll have school classes college
classes taught about it but do i think
it'll change one person's mind no and
that's why what we're doing right now is
so important what we're doing is we're
trying to activate activate the people
that know he's guilty and hold him
accountable for his improper actions and
those that were around him for their
improper actions that's what my hope
that this hearing will ultimately show
do i think it'll change people's minds
no but do i think that it could hold
somebody responsible more than trump
i shouldn't say more than trump i meant
somebody other than trump there will be
other people held accountable but i
believe it will be very difficult for
department of justice to end up
indicting trump as much as i would like
to see that happen as much as i'm sure
the people that are watching us right
now would like to see that happen my
biggest concern is that donald trump who
does not have his fingerprints on
anything he learned very very well from
the attorney roy cohn years ago have
your fingerprints on nothing so i think
that this is going to be one of those
hearings that there'll be a lot of
information a lot of people are going to
say the things that you already know but
you're going to hear other people saying
it as opposed to reading it
you know i think it's interesting that
you bring up the
the separation between donald and the
crime right um because you've
experienced this in federal court
yourself
but we see so many different levels of
this this crime of him trying to take
away our vote trying to subvert
democracy to not have that peaceful
transfer of power
not only in the prowl boys or the oath
keepers but we see it in the doj where
he tried to you know subvert that in the
doj in georgia he tried to call brad
rathis burger
and tried to get them to find 11 000
votes whatever the whatever the exactly
11
780 they're saying the same you know
repetition that fox news and everybody
wants to talk about or let's build the
wall and who's going to pay for it
that's just that's just the way donald
trump behaves you know he's a master of
media manipulation right so let's talk
about those different levels do you
think this hearing is going to give us a
sense
of
leading to donald trump with these
different levels do you think it's going
to show us a road map of the evidence
where he was trying to
distance himself from the actual crime
do you think it's do you think these
hearings are going to show us that this
one in particular but the other ones do
you think it's going to show us that
yeah i do i think what they're doing
right now is they're setting this up as
a road map they're going to start out
with people who are in the room they're
going to talk about donald's impressions
when he was there what he said who he
set it to you know where he disappeared
to i mean there's like what 187 minutes
where he was completely off the grid i
want people to think about that for a
second so you're the president of the
united states of america and
your obligation is to ensure
right that the country is safe and
protected that's really probably the
primary obligation a president has to
the rest of us to you know to the people
to whom elected him or
those of us that didn't you know um vote
for him but nevertheless ended up he
became you know president of the united
states of america all right
instead not only is he not doing that
he's actually enjoying watching a coup
against our country i mean that's
that's going to be a big part of what
you're going to hear tonight now what do
you think you're going to hear from
counter programming on the other side
whether it's going to be trump's folks i
mean i heard lara trump today you know
came out and made some stupid ass
comment that no one's going to watch it
because we all already know that donald
has no uh you know no he has no
fingerprints on this and that he had
nothing to do with it i mean the
this disco really needs some serious
therapy i mean especially considering
the fact that donald didn't even like
her and didn't want eric to marry her
but now all of a sudden because she says
these crazy things now all of a sudden
she's a fan favorite to him the whole
donald is seriously off his rocker and i
can tell you that these hearings will
ultimately set
set in motion
at least some sort of a chronology of
what took place who was involved you
know who had some action towards it but
then again you know at the end of the
day what what do we really need we need
the members of this committee to refer
it to the justice department to refer
the matter to merrick garland for
prosecution and my biggest fear is that
merrick garland is not going to do that
he does not want to be seen as political
in any way despite i believe what all of
this information is going to you know
it's going to shed light on and that's
really a shame because we are all going
to watch this and we're going to be
scratching our heads and saying holy
[ __ ] did this guy really do that did
this guy really turn around and speak to
mark meadows who's on the phone for
example with somebody else on these burn
of phones
did somebody really provide a road map
uh of the inside of the capitol so that
people can find my fence that people can
find nancy pelosi's office or get to the
senatorial chamber so that they can stop
the transfer of you know of the of
democracy and to prevent joe biden from
being um you know sworn in i mean i i
truly don't understand
how people can stop
and and say
donald had nothing to do with it and
that's what you're gonna hear tonight
it's the continuation of a witch hunt
nothing is really new here it's the same
bs that they've been trying to put on
donald since the day he was elected uh
you're gonna hear again those words like
witch hunt it's it's a lie they fear the
republicans that that democrats know
that republicans are going to take the
house and probably the senate and in
2024 that would they're going to take
the the white house as well they're
going to have all three parts and this
and that democrats of course are afraid
of it and so we're attacking their
leader their king maker right donald
himself and
watch just watch and this is what you're
going to see because this is their
playbook and that's what trump has shown
the republicans to do i want people to
remember when i was testifying before
the house oversight committee did one
republican ask a single question no
not one and i made mention of that i
said isn't anybody gonna ask me a single
question about donald isn't that why i
was asked to come here instead what did
they do
they lie
they denigrate you they turn around and
they all use the same buzzwords that are
provided to them by whether it's a steve
bannon whether it's by a steve miller
whether it's by you know um don jr or by
ivanko or jared it's by any one of those
that were in close proximate um distance
to donald where he would say to him i
want this word used and then they just
send it out as a massive email and you
will hear the same words over and over
and over again because look it's one
thing that trump has picked up from
history not that he ever read a history
book but he picked up that stalin used
to do this if you want if you want to
change people's mindset you got to say
the same lie over and over and over
again until the lie becomes the truth
michael i i appreciate your insight into
not just trump but the trump orbit
because i think that is most important
what we're going to see here with some
of these hearings is the trump orbit
really was engaged not just not just in
the attempt to subvert democracy but to
try to protect whatever it is that they
try to protect around who donald donald
is only donald it's crazy that they
would give their entire their entire
being to this one person thanks for
getting an insight michael stick around
because after um if we have a break in
the hearing i want to bring you back on
your thoughts about the hearing and then
after the hearing if you can stick
around because i'd love i'd love to hear
what your take is on the entirety of
this particular presentation that
they're going to give tonight you know
tony before we split i want people to
understand you a lot of people turn
around they
will send me text messages or they'll go
to instagram or facebook or uh my
twitter account they'll say why are you
yelling why are you why do you always
sound like you're you know um you just
had five cups of coffee i'm angry and i
want that anger to come through
to each and every one of you and that's
why in like one of the last youtube
videos that might just put out i turned
around and i said call call republican
members of congress if we don't do
something now then when what are we
going to do you're going to turn around
after you take your head out of the sand
and you realize that trump just
destroyed democracy that what are we
going to do now how are we going to get
it back once we lose it and i want
people to understand and i say this all
the time democracy is not a god-given
right it's something that we have to
fight and protect every single day and
once we lose democracy here in this
country especially to somebody like
donald trump or a donald trump 2.0 we're
never getting it back so if we're not
going to get angry now if we're not
going to mobilize if we're not if we are
not going to be a movement then all of
this is for naught and what a shame
could you imagine what a shame
thank you michael for joining us i
really do appreciate it uh please stick
around if you can during the if we have
a break and then after because i'd
really like to get your take on stuff
thank you thank you michael for joining
us we'll talk about you all talk to you
soon my friend uh
absolutely um insight into donald trump
and also the family because i i think
that's important with this hearing
because
we're supposed to hear
some testimony from
ivanka trump and jared kushner that they
gave to the january 6th select committee
um
i don't know if it's video or audio i'm
not really sure exactly what we're going
to get but i hope it's video because i
want to see some viral video come from
this speaking of viral video
the midas mighty out there will know
texas paul everyone loves texas ball the
mighty midas mighty uh he's a tick
tocker and again uh
midas
touch youtube extraordinaire um paul how
are you
i am wonderful i am wonderful
i'm glad you i'm glad you joined us i'm
glad you joined us uh what's what's your
first thoughts here um before we get
into the hearings well i have to tell
you i have to start with a little psa i
apologize uh my inbox has been blown up
uh we've had health departments all the
way from marina del rey to martha's
vineyard
uh just asking me to please do a public
service announcement that people not
include the words
donald trump
traitor or treason in their
january 6th hearing drinking games you
know we all know the tragedies we had
with it with the fraternities that put i
do not recall in their drinking game
during the martha uh trainer green
hearings and and you know how that ended
up in the emergency room so we've got to
we've got to be very careful no no i'm
just good well you know i definitely i
definitely i think people could play um
drinking games with these hearings uh
the word insurrection possibly the word
coup the word traitor might come up i
don't
sedition is definitely gonna come up in
these hearings so um if anyone out there
is popping popcorn and playing drinking
games you might pick out a few words
that you would go with um but uh i i
guess i guess some of the trolls didn't
want us to say the word traitor uh next
to the word donald trump but you know i
i i'm
everybody knows out there uh i i'm not
scared to say something so what i what i
really want to get though is because you
you have had these videos where you
express your anger in a certain way um
so tell us
tell us about the lead up to january 6
and how you felt about it at the time
and then
watching it on tv and now here we are
all this time later we're finally
getting to find out what the lead up was
tell us in a few words
how you how you felt about that tell us
tell us well i have to tell you leading
up to january 6th i i really want you to
think back to that and i have to
disagree with michael cohen on one point
i think this is going to be very
eye-opening to people because most
people don't know just how close we came
to the ultimate disaster of losing our
democracy what he said about the danger
of donald trump was right on the money
and that's what was getting me leading
up to january 6th what you know because
i i did a deep dive on everything that
had gone on
and and you know
donald trump that he talked about the
187 minutes where donald trump was out
of touch donald trump was waiting for
something if you remember the lead up to
january 6th
everything on social media was baiting
by the proud boys and and the
you know nutty right wing
trying to make as much noise about this
rally as possible
they wanted
us to respond and i don't know if you
remember hearing all over social media
calls from people like me and everyone
else
stay out of dc
stay out of dc
don't show up on january 6th
don't give them an excuse and if you
look at what happened on january 6th
you know they had molotov cocktails and
trucks waiting they had bombs that were
functional fully functional bombs
planted and ready to go
had we shown up had antifa shown up had
any substantial
presence at all shown up from the left
we would have been blamed for january 6.
fox news already had the talking points
forgive me they were already saying it's
antifa it's blm it's everything else and
when it turned out to just be hours and
hours and hours of seeing
trump's supporters
you know desecrate our capital attacking
our police officers
you know and on and on smearing feces in
our capital
it didn't happen it did not happen what
they had planned was for
their quick reaction force that they had
just across the river armed to the teeth
were going to show up and they were
going to declare the incident you know a
state of emergency in the insurrection
act
and donald trump was going to delay the
certification of the results and you
know the sunset clause
that would have sent it sent it back to
congress and you remember the math on
that don't you i mean in the house they
go state to state one vote one state and
the republicans owned more states at the
time i absolutely believe that we are
going to see in these hearings it laid
out
that they had a 100
plan
to hand the election back to donald
trump
through the use of the insurrection i i
absolutely agree with you i think
there's a lot with the seditious
conspiracy that we've seen in the
superseding indictment for the proud
boys and the oath keepers also the
decision from judge carter out of
california with john eastman and that
plan for michael pence
the vice president at the time who would
not get into and i hope that's one thing
we get to in these hearings whether it's
today or in these uh hearings in the
next few weeks about why mike pence
wouldn't get into the the van with the
secret service paul i really appreciate
you coming stick around because um
i'll bring you back in and hopefully
either at the break or at the end if
you've got a chance um and we'll get
some more commentary make sure you make
notes because i know i know you'll have
tons of stuff to rant on thank you very
much sir we'll talk to you very soon yep
uh
i i think i think there's a lot of stuff
that
we could actually say about this hearing
in these hearings but i think the one
question that we want to ask is why
should we care about these hearings
because that is something
that i think everyone's probably
wondering like why the hell should we
care what does it matter what does it
matter if we watch it if we don't watch
it if we consume it or we don't because
we watched for weeks and weeks and weeks
the johnny depp and amber her child and
we definitely should have cared about
that in this country but here we are
here we are why should we care and i
have someone that i want to ask this
question to
uh you know her as politics girl lee
mcgowan politics girl podcast lee how
are you
i'm good i mean i'm good i was it's
interesting to listen to paul and
michael talk because
you know
michael said it's going to be a lot like
the mueller report and god i hope not
you know that was a real disappointment
and
uh i don't think so i think the people
in charge of this i think we're in a
totally different situation here but i
will say i agree with him
when he talks about when people say why
are you yelling you know why are you
angry because i often say the same thing
i say like why aren't you angry you know
and when we're talking about this
situation that's happening today i'm i'm
listening to a lot of people and i'm
reading a lot of people and they're
basically saying you know
who cares this was a long time ago you
know let's not take our eyes off the
ball for midterms or i'm more interested
in inflation or gas prices or whatever
um that people don't
really care about one six anymore and
that makes me crazy because
it reminds me of when you
get sick you know when you get sick and
your whole life stops and you can't do
anything all of a sudden you're like i
can't believe i took breathing for
granted or getting out of bread for
granted you know and that could be
anything from a cold to covet but if you
get really sick if you're someone that's
diagnosed with something terrible um of
course we worry about our job and our
kids and our bank account but when you
get really sick that becomes your sole
focus
and
i believe the country is really sick
and what happened on january 6th was
just a physical manifestation of how
sick the body politic is
like we have this giant tumor
and it's metastasizing it's growing
bigger every day and we can't ignore it
because we're worried about gas prices
or inflation if we don't address this
tumor that is attacking our country
will die you know america will die it's
very fragile right now and we have to
look at the 1-6 committee
as basically the diagnostic tools that
you have when you get ill you know
the pet scan machine the mri machine the
blood test that you do they have done
all the research and the interviews and
the investigation right they're going to
lay out the picture of exactly what is
wrong with us how we got here and what
they think we should do and it's up to
us to listen to them um
and then from there when we know truly
what's wrong with us and how far it goes
and how deep it's gone into our body
then we need to proactively deal with
this illness and that is going to be
through the action of congress based on
the recommendations of this committee
that's going to be what the doj does um
to hold people accountable and that's
going to be what the voters do right at
the midterms in the 24 election and the
elections following that because we need
to cut this tumor out of our country we
need to proactively deal with this
disease of misinformation and lies and
corruption that is killing the country
and to do that we need all the facts and
ignoring the facts and not watching
these hearings is not going to make it
go away it's just going to make us
sicker and
if anyone who's ever been sick knows
without our health we have nothing
i completely agree with you and i have
another question for you because you
bring up the republicans and what their
view of it is because
they've been saying all day you know fox
news isn't airing this they're like oh
this is all
this is all [ __ ] you know uh
don't listen to what the facts are you
know facts don't matter because i think
that's part of the sickness right is
what you're talking about is
this this absolute obsession with
i call it the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life that's where
i put it right
we're in a situation where people they
it feels good to believe some of these
things right so tell me about the belief
that this is a kangaroo court and you
know how
what do you think about that about the
idea that somehow this is all fake and
tell us about that sickness
uh well you know that your theory of it
being like wrestlemania is is true you
know i think it goes back to what
michael was saying earlier that donald
trump is the master of manipulation
right he's he's a showman he's a
ringleader he's
um he's the leader of what's really
happening here which is this constant
disinformation same words over and over
something that the democrats are just
not that good at right the republicans
are very good at doing this and they're
out here right now saying it's all
partisan it's all for show it's a
kangaroo court uh and the only reason it
would be even similar to a kangaroo
court is that the committee itself has
no real power for accountability right
they they're gonna as i said lay out the
story but they can't do anything aside
from make recommendations um
so
that would be the only way it would be
like a fake court which is what a
kangaroo court is really considered but
in this case
the idea that the republicans saying
it's partisan and and this shouldn't be
happening they don't really have a leg
to stand on there because
we all watched the insurrection happen
we all watched one six live on
television and it was shocking people
can remember it wasn't really that long
ago it was shocking it was the biggest
attack in our capital since 1812 and
people died it was an appalling
uh
degradation of our government and our
country um and then afterwards the house
was understandably shocked and they
wanted to set up a 911 style bipartisan
commission to investigate it but the
republicans voted against it right they
first made a whole bunch of ridiculous
demands they wanted to have um
an even number of republican and
democratic members they wanted to have
subpoena power they wanted to have veto
over subpoenas they wanted to have an
end date of december 2021 so they could
keep it out of this election year and
you would think the democrats would say
well no that's too many and this is
we're going to make some concessions but
they gave the republicans every single
thing they asked for they said sure you
can have an equal number sure you can
veto our subpoenas sure we can be done
by december 2021. and then the
republicans went forward and voted
against it anyway
so no 9 11 style bipartisan commission
but the country still wanted to know
what happened so nancy pelosi she used
her power and she set up a
benghazi style
commission and uh that's what we have
today this committee and she said to
kevin mccarthy like look i have seven
members you will get six members um and
kevin mccarthy said i'm not playing ball
i won't do it none of my members are
allowed to be part of your committee not
a single one and if they try and be part
of your committee i'm going to strip
them of their
position of power
and unfortunately he had already gone
head-to-head with liz cheney right so
liz cheney said you know what i'll be on
your committee and so nancy pelosi said
to kevin mccarthy you know what i've got
one of yours why don't you give me five
more and so he named five more people
and two of them happen to be
uh pro-insurrectionists
very pro-donald trump pro-stop the steel
republicans um including jim jordan and
nancy pelosi said you know what we'll
take these three but these two cannot be
part of the committee they're basically
co-conspirators pick two more and kevin
made a huge big show oh i can't have my
people and he pulled all five of his
people so nancy pelosi said okay well
i've got one which makes it bipartisan
and i've got my people which are the
majority so we have a quorum we're going
to move forward and then adam kinzinger
joined so this idea that the republicans
are saying it's such a shock and we
can't believe that they're doing this
you had every opportunity to have an
equal amount of people you had every
opportunity to veto subpoenas and have
subpoenas and ask their questions you
voted against it then you were offered
to have people on this committee you
didn't do it so now we're in this
position where we're going to lay out
some facts and they're not there to get
in the way they're not there to obstruct
and they're very upset about it but
honestly
it's their own fault right i always
think about republicans when they're
they were there the day of the event and
they were so surprised that it was
happening and and a lot of them even
people like mitch mcconnell they were
saying donald trump did this he needs to
call it off they all were speaking truth
in that moment on the day when they were
shocked
and then
they started rolling it back and
changing the narrative and pulling it
all together because they play like a
team they're very very smart right and i
always think about those parents that
defend their children who have murdered
someone or defend their children who
have raped someone or buried someone's
body in the everglades and you think why
are they covering for them like their
child is clearly so guilty they know it
but they just can't stop themselves they
are
the republicans are basically the
parents of criminals right they're
covering up for the people responsible
because it serves them and that's what
we have to keep in mind these are just
facts that they're going to lay out what
happens after those facts is dependent
on the doj it's dependent on congress
and it's dependent on the voter
i i appreciate your commentary and you
always have a great way of putting
things um so elite stick around please
if we have a break or after i would love
to get your take on the information that
we actually receive um i'm gonna go get
some legal analysis you have a great way
of setting up the political part of it
and so now now i'm gonna go to karen
agnipolo and get some legal some legal
analysis so thank you lee if you can
stay with us throughout the the night
and we'll come to you for some more
political commentary thank you lee we
really are wonderful everyone look
forward to hearing yes everyone go
download the poll and takes girl podcast
thank you thank you lee thank you
so i want to i want to bring up i want
to bring up karen agnivolo because i
think that one thing that we we need to
have is the legal analysis of this whole
thing um because that is part of this
there is a legal aspect to this because
on the other side of the january 6
committee this evidence that we're going
to see there's possible criminal
indictments and there is currently
there's people sitting in prison with
their bare feet on the floor and i got
that freeze from kfa karen mcgivolo from
legal af podcast karen how are you great
i am so i'm so excited to have you i had
popock your co-host on wednesdays on my
show today and i thought maybe he was
going to join you here
i i think he didn't want to predict
things so he's going to join us
somewhere near the end
but i'm glad to have you uh the legal af
er here
um with us so tell me about the legal
part of this because we've heard some
political commentary we heard from
michael cohen about kind of the mindset
of trump and people around trump but
tell me about the legal part of this
because there is legal parts of this
maybe not in the select committee
necessarily maybe with some of the
contempt charges but really what does
this evidence mean with the doj because
that's always the question oh
you know this select it's all it's all a
show the doj is not actually going to do
anything so tell us about the
prosecution it is prosecutable so so
just my background is as a prosecutor i
was um a three-decade prosecutor at the
manhattan da's office in new york so
i look at this from the lens of a
prosecutor and i as and from the lens of
a trial attorney and
uh
what's happening in parallel to this is
the department of justice it does have a
criminal investigation into the events
of january 6 as we all know it's been
widely reported and over 800 people have
been
arrested and it's mostly the
insurrectionists who have been arrested
and and a lot of people are wondering
what what about
donald trump and what about
his his close circle of advisers and
when
is the investigation going to rope them
in um many people have said that this
house select committee should should
make a criminal referral i heard michael
cohen say that
i would argue that i would hope that
they would not make a criminal referral
because doj doesn't need it doj is
investigating the case they will be
watching these hearings they will see
what evidence they have if they want the
evidence they will either ask for it or
subpoena it they don't need a criminal
referral and the reason i hope they
don't make one is because then you're
injecting politics into criminal justice
and that is the death knell of criminal
justice people have to trust the legal
system and the justice system and it
can't be political
and it has to just be you look at the
evidence and you follow the evidence
without fear or favor you don't go with
the people you agree with or disagree
with you follow the evidence wherever it
may lead and you don't have a political
bent and you know this particular uh
select committee i think has two
problems number one it's obviously
political it's you know it's it's these
are politicians who are part of the
legislative branch so you know and their
job is to make laws and
you know they they can advise and they
can and they can do these investigations
but it's not a criminal investigation
this is an advisory uh this is sort of
an advisory body that can inform the
public and inform um sort of what
happened and they have spoken to um what
is it over a thousand people have come
and given testimony and hopefully we'll
see some of that they've gathered lots
and lots of of
videos and audios and emails and text
messages and like a criminal trial you
know when you you get all of this
information and it and it kind of gets
dumped in and and at summation at the
end your closing argument is when you
can sort of weave it all together and
tell the story of what it means so i'm
hoping that this that these hearings are
like a summation that of all the the
evidence that they've gathered of all
the people they've spoken to that they
will weave it all together and tell
everyone what it means like the best
summations you've seen and and hopefully
give a road map to not just the public
but also to the people who are
investigating this from a criminal
perspective so they too can can bring
the case my other concern
and i have a few concerns about this
this committee
is um what's really unprecedented is
they were the victims of the crime the
people the people in the house were
there that day on january 6 in fear of
their life they are witnesses themselves
and so it it seems very strange to me
and could potentially
lose their credibility but that they're
the ones doing the investigation i mean
imagine i was a sexual assault
prosecutor for a very long time imagine
a rape victim being the jury
the judge and the prosecutor you know
and the witness you're not going to get
you know
even if it's the best information even
if it's the best evidence one could call
into question you know the the sort of
objectivity so i'm just really hoping
that they're careful and that they don't
make this
you know that that you know as michael
cohen said and you know that that donald
trump is a master media manipulator was
the words he used and i'm i fear and i
worry that the house committee is is
going to try to compete with him on that
level and they hired a you know the
former
i don't know what he was of abc news and
documentarian to produce this hearing
and an overly produced overly glossy
hearing could have the era of
inauthenticity and i don't want to lose
the hearts and minds of people because
of these concerns i'm raising and so so
i'm just concerned because i do think in
the end you're going to have a justice
department who's going to have to look
at evidence and to decide
did donald trump commit a crime and does
the evidence support that and and these
187 minutes where he was off the grid
you know
that is not evidence that that doesn't
show he did anything we all know there's
an insurrection we all know that people
breach the capital we all i mean that's
why there's over 800 prosecutions
already happening and so those people
are responsible but this committee is
going to have to lay out in detail what
did donald trump do that has admissible
evidence in court
that will lead a jury to be able to
convict him of crimes and so that is i
think one of the most important
tasks they can that they can do here so
it has to be authentic it can't be you
know a spectacle it has to be
substantive
and they have to really capture
the hearts and minds of of people who
are out there even people who are
like-minded and agree with this position
i think you have to get them to care and
you know i worry a little bit jamie
raskin said you know we're gonna blow
the roof off the house you know
hopefully that wasn't an over promise
hopefully they blow the roof off and i'm
right i'm you know really excited i'm
really really excited to see this and
watch it but it it cannot lack
authenticity and they have to be careful
because like i said they are also the
victims of the crime as much as they are
the people gathering information and
gathering the evidence so so those are
sort of my thoughts and concerns because
you know in the end real really what we
want is we want a prosecution of donald
trump and so you know don't f it up for
for the for the
time you know hear that select committee
don't you you know
i'll say it don't [ __ ] it up for garen
here don't because you know
prosecutors know what they're doing
that's right and the department of
justice has some of the best prosecutors
in the country and you know they have to
trust them don't you think we have to
trust them and they're doing their job
and don't eff it up right
i appreciate it and karen i know you're
going to be making notes this entire
this entire process so so so when you
have your notes please join us again as
the others hopefully will um after the
hearing to give me your take on some of
the notes that you have so thank you for
coming and we'll talk to you soon my
friend thanks for having me
um so we're going to go we're going to
go to she was speaking of the politics
of it and convincing people so i want to
go to some political strategist um here
and i think we got the sound test done
is ali and adam are they ready can you
give me a thumbs up if you're ready
uh it looks like yeah they're ready okay
we're gonna pull them in here hey how
are you guys
how's it going oh going going great
going great we're just uh we're just
trailing through this broadcast it looks
like um it looks like we have i'm gonna
show you guys something here we've got
the uh the stream going here you see the
capital here in the background i want to
show everybody
we're about um just about 15 minutes
away
from hearing this hearing but i want you
guys to really give us a sense
of the the political strategy because
everyone's saying all the democrats are
trying to politicize this and i've been
making the case for
you know many many many many weeks that
yes they should politicize this they
should so tell us about the political
strategy of this after these hearings
are over because history is about to be
made
who wants to go first i'll go for it go
ahead go ahead yeah i mean i think for
for months it's been almost a year and a
half since the attack um last january of
2021 and people have been wondering what
is going on you know they haven't seen
anything they haven't really seen these
hearings being played uh publicly and
for the public to consume so i think
that this is really really like a great
step forward for
um just publicizing what's actually been
going on behind closed doors
and um
yeah i just i think that
um this is this is the chance to show
exactly what the january 6 committee has
been up to and has been working on this
whole time they said it's been kind of
like building up uh from the bottom up
and so i think that we're all ready to
see what they've been what they've been
preparing
yeah i totally agree i think that you
know i totally agree with you we should
we should be partisan but at the same
time the the facts are on our side i
love that democrats are doing this at
prime time you know in in using the
tactics that republicans constantly use
against us the facts being on our side
we should make sure that the entire
country can hear this someone said
earlier today that there's a poll out
saying that you know independents aren't
sure if donald trump contributed you
know contributed this insurrection and
then you've got kevin mccarthy coming
out saying every single person in this
country is responsible for the
insurrection well kevin mccarthy's
talking directly to those independents
saying that you know they are very much
responsible for this insurrection just
as much as he is um i think it's going
to be an interesting night um i agree
with what was said earlier in terms of
you know setting expectations but at the
same time it's nice to hear about you
know hear someone saying they're going
to blow the roof off the house and
they're using an analogy as opposed to
physical violence and and you know i
think that democrats have everything
including history on their side and they
need to just go out there
and shine a big light on this and do it
at a point where uh where everyone's
paying attention to it what we see we
see now in the room they've got the
screen going um and it looks like the
hearing's going to start soon i
appreciate and you guys please stick
around i'd like to get more commentary
either in between if we have a break or
after we're going to have all kinds of
time after the hearing once we hear what
is being said as history is made tonight
again this hearing is going to start in
less than 15 minutes so i want to bring
in another political strategist thank
you adam thank you ali for for joining
us i want to bring in another political
strategist and i want his take because
he really he really pulls in the history
of all this um he was around when
watergate we were talking years ago and
i think almost our country owes an
apology to richard nixon at this point
seeing how much evidence we have of how
much crime was actually committed by
donald trump and the people who were
trying to overturn our vote and trying
to overturn our democracy i want to
introduce you to
david bender he's a political strategist
um he's gonna
i talked to him earlier he said he's
gonna tell us
just exactly how old he is david how are
you
can you hear me there david i can hear
you fine hey great i'm not gonna tell
you how old i am oh okay well you you i
will tell you i will tell you
that during the fall of rome okay very
clear to caesar do not turn your back on
brutus
mistake and people listen they never
listen that's so you remember you
remember coos all the way back to that
and and the truth is in remembering
coups there's an and this is a serious
point tony
every successful coup is preceded by a
failed one
we had a failed coup
on january 6 but failed only for the
short term
it's still going on right now and that's
the thing that this committee is
addressing what we're gonna see over the
next
six sessions starting tonight
is they're gonna deal with the reality
that this did not end on january 6th it
didn't end today those people are
planning this for this fall
for november and for beyond into 2024.
this is a very organized effort to not
make the mistakes they made by leaving
it to mike pence to do the right thing
right right well we see this hearing
getting set up i want to pull on my
co-host because i think gabe might have
a question for you uh gabe welcome
welcome to the broadcast uh you you got
your your mic yeah there we go
um
so so i want to see if you've got a
question for david because i know
i know you've been in the green room
trying to do some sound tests and you've
been listening but do you have a
question for david about the direction
i think i think what most of us are
pretty curious about is like you know if
you could kind of anticipate what this
presentation or the at least the layout
or the format in which they're gonna
make the case for you know against
donald trump and against the cohorts
that he you know trying to overthrow the
government you know what what would that
look like i can try and tell you and and
obviously we're waiting for chairman
thompson to gavel this in uh so we've
got
about nine minutes so let me do this in
two
what we're going to see tonight is an
overview chairman thompson's going to
open this uh he is going to talk about
why they're there what this matter why
it matters and specifically about the
events of january 6th then we're going
to see some footage
uh it's a little bit of a spoiler alert
but we're going to see
footage coming up i think we may be
seeing it right now
that that in fact we all have seen but
we're going to see footage we've never
seen before because there are body cams
and things that
the committee has
this will be brand new to the audience
this isn't the greatest hits clip this
is new stuff
out of that out of that footage we're
going to come in to loose chain
and vice chair liz cheney who as uh was
observed earlier by a politics girl it
went on you know because she did the
right thing in spite of her party saying
you'll never have a future in this party
if you do it
i've never agreed with liz cheney on a
single political issue
but i have enormous respect for her
integrity and what she's going to say
tonight
she is going to say
this is what we're going to see over the
next
five hearings as well as tonight we're
going to lay out this case the arc of
the story
and the arc
that began before january 6. let's be
very very clear this started in november
this started even before
trump lost
they had a plan in place if he did
then they began to implement it that's
the and then we're going to hear all
about these fake electors and all about
all of these efforts to overturn the
results so liz cheney laid that out
tonight
then we're gonna hear from two we're
gonna take a break
uh then there'll be two fact witnesses
one is the capital hill policewoman
who was
on the front lines and a proud boy and
his mother must be really proud of him
because he knocked her to the ground she
had a concussion
she will testify caroline edwards will
testify tonight
and
the geniuses that are the proud boys and
uh the oath keepers
allowed a british documentary filmmaker
nick quested
to
embed with them
and he covered the proud boys while they
were planning the insurrection
and that footage speaking of watergate
it's footage in a garage
where these two groups met we're going
to see that tonight
so
in answer gave to your question that's
what's going to play out tonight
we may
we may
and and just sit on the edge of your
seat to see
there is a
videotape of the depositions of jared
and ivanka about what went on in those
three hours that the capital was under
assault and specifically ivanka
who we know
tried to get her father to take an
action
so the question tonight and the question
over the course of the next
five hearings after tonight
is what did the president not do
and when did he not do it
i i think that's a great question
because i think that's kind of the
unanswered right like that that time
period that maybe
um the testimony of
uh ivanka trump and jared kushner will
give but i want to go back to that video
that you're going to see of of the proud
boys and the oath keepers planning the
insurrection
i think that's very significant i talked
to michael bobock from legally after day
and he really focused on the doj part of
it but what we see now
um inside the doj prosecuting some of
these insurrectionists we see the people
actually charged with seditious
conspiracy are oath keepers and proud
boys
do you think
i mean i'm surmising here but i would
imagine doj has that footage just as
well as the select committee has that
footage but how much of it are we really
gonna see i mean david are you telling
me that we're going to see the stuff
that spells out the crimes right out in
the open here yes i think we are because
there are existing indictments i don't
think
well one of the things that they have to
be careful about and i i thought that
the legal analysis of the fact that
these people
the members of the house were in fact
victims of this crime
is
if there are jury trials for some of the
people involved and they're not
cooperating but they stand trial
then you don't want to use all of the
evidence here so there's there's a dance
that's going on between doj and the
committee
uh but it's a it's a friendly dance
they're they're working
cooperatively and trying to stay in step
with each other so that what doesn't
happen is that uh evidence that's put
out here biases a jury in the future i
do think we're going to see
some very significant footage tonight
that that sets the stage we may not see
all of it we don't need to we just need
to know that it happened they were
talking uh you know uh ontario wasn't
even supposed to be there
legally there's a lot of things that
will be revealed tonight uh that i think
will get people's interest they just
don't know
some of these characters
well you know gabe actually found some
some of the clips of the video and he
talked about today on the um the
broadcast that channel 4 actually had
some of that video taken down because we
see
we see tario like you're saying who is
just recently um
givens the charges of conditions
seditious conspiracy in the superseding
indictment the same charges that we've
seen some of the oath keepers actually
plead guilty to in court brian ulrich in
particular said yes judge i was in a
plot to plan to make sure with stuart
rhodes that there was no peaceful
transfer of power which is a very
significant wording but gabe found this
video and he's really um gabe's kind of
seen some of this proud boy oath keeper
stuff
so gabe do you have really any other
questions about because i think this is
so significant that the the the the the
documentary film is going to tie the
oath keepers and the proud boys too
because we're going to go live and the
minute that gavel comes in we're all
going
yeah so i've seen i've seen multiple
parts before they pulled it down
basically them meeting on january 5th in
the parking garage between latinos for
trump uh proud boys and the oath keepers
there's also footage of tario getting
released from court which again like you
said he was not supposed to be in dc on
january 5th he was supposed to be
outside of the city by that point
explain to the audience why that was
because that's significant too right so
they really
you know free insurrection rallies right
yeah he he got busted for burning the
blm flag
outside of the church and that's what
ultimately got him in trouble where the
court said you have to now remove
yourself from dc but of course you know
being a
person who wants to throw an
insurrection uh doesn't listen goes to a
parking garage in a shady area and has a
planning session with other people who
also
want to form this conspiracy for
sedition so i think if anything we'll
probably yes we'll see video footage
we'll probably hear actual the testimony
from the documentarian but that's the
thing that there have been clips
from this that are somewhere on the
internet i have a couple of them myself
but the actual whole footage itself from
the documentary has been pulled by
channel 4 and i imagine
that's due to the committee subpoena
subpoenaing the the actual
uh video and and saying you need to
remove it
you know i feel like we should have a
ball here that's going to drop like it's
new year's and right right now we're
waiting on the countdown aren't we right
yeah we're at three in a moment and i'm
sure every other network actually has a
little clock i'm glad we don't because
it's it's been overdone now but let me
let me make one point as we go into this
yeah and you mentioned watergate which
for
me at a time i was in high school
was incredibly significant to the point
where the entire country was watching
john dean then 34 years old testify
and bring down a presidency a presidency
that had won 49 states that uh nixon's
reelection won 49 states
uh he was at a high level very high
popularity when the watergate hearing
started
and he resigned in august of 74
at 20 something percent approval his
numbers continue to plummet
tonight
tonight if we all watch and then we keep
watching and that's the most important
thing i can say to people who are
listening to this
keep watching keep watching uh on monday
uh the next four hearings are all going
to be
at 10 a.m eastern seven o'clock pacific
uh watch those hearings as they unfold
and then on the 23rd
i think two weeks from now it will again
be in prime time to wrap it up
but if we watch the way we did in
watergate if we watch as a country and
keep talking about it
it's gonna move the dial people will
understand that this was a crime against
the nation and donald trump
the sitting president tried to undo
the constitutional transfer of power
it's never happened before it must never
happen again you know benny thompson
actually had a statement the other day
publicly that um they were going to lay
out in these hearings the what they were
going to do to make sure this did not
happen again um
but
i said earlier that we almost owe um
richard nixon an apology
some some some actually some actually
remember watergate um through history
but some of us remember in that moment
and you were in that moment so does this
have a different feeling do you
one administration that was corrupt and
there have been many uh the harding
administration at teapot dome
you know i i can go all michael
beschloss on you and tell you all of
these things but the important thing to
know is none of those threaten the
existence of the republic
this does
this is left unaccounted for
everything that we are built on which
started with the peaceful transfer of
power when
john adams who hated thomas jefferson
hated it
handed over the presidency conceded that
he lost
they then later became great friends but
the point is
no matter the personal animus
uh history has shown that we we must
unite around a winner
and
the problem is what's what is
established now and that's what the
republican playbook is you saw
with dr oz trump said just declare
victory
no recounts declare it that's going to
be their their operating principle
that's why this has to change that's why
we have to look back in order to move
forward
and that's what's going to happen
tonight people who say this doesn't
matter don't understand that the only
way
the way germany has become a democracy
is there were nuremberg trials right
they were held to account for their
crimes
donald trump and the criminal
conspirators who were part of this
must be held to account
or i guarantee you it will happen again
chairman thompson is approaching
i see that i see that
david
i yield back the balance of my time for
the chairman yes yes yes well thank you
very much and uh we will we will um we
will go to
vinnie thompson here really quick
thank you david for joining us stick
around for more commentary committed to
investigate the january 6th attack
on the united states capitol will be in
order
the chair declares the committee in
recess
for a period of approximately 10 minutes
so it appears that we're going to be
going to a break gabe that video is
something else don't you think jesus wow
um absolutely crazy um especially at the
end there when you compare it to the
the violence the non-tour that is
um the insurrection of january 6 and
donald trump's description of it which
was [ __ ] absolutely ridiculous
um
i i can't wait to find out exactly what
he was being described and how it was
being described to him uh in the room of
course we know some of this because
you've even read some of these text
messages um right that we've seen that
were from
sean hannity that were from laura in
museum yeah
i mean we we see we see
text messages from from donald trump jr
even yep junior even saying we have to
stop this because they understood the
ramifications they understand what was
happening they knew what was going on
they knew this was a violent attack they
knew they knew that the president united
states
was sitting back and letting these
people try to take the congress try to
take the building i have never been on a
tour of the capitol but i can't imagine
having a ticket to a tour and this is
the way that you would actually uh
behave during a tour i'm gonna bring in
uh kfa i'm gonna bring in karen agnivolo
here um to see what her reaction is to
some of this i know she probably has a
lot of notes yeah
karen how are you
are you are you set up there i know you
were you were trying to get back to your
your your spot there what um what do you
take from some of the evidence but the
video at the end is um
is groundbreaking no one has ever seen
that video apparently the the way it was
put together but the evidence they laid
out before that video um
was deafening but the video is
absolutely detrimental to the case that
somehow this was just a tour and it was
not a coup it was not just a normal
tourist visit i don't know anyone who
could have watched that video and still
said yeah
you know representative clyde was
totally right it was just a tourist
visit right that is complete 100 utter
[ __ ] well and and you have
experience in looking at video evidence
as as a criminal prosecutor so what was
your take not just on some of the notes
you have from the from the evidence that
the chairman and liz cheney laid out but
this video that that they had
so i think the the compilation video was
very effective the fact that they had
the times you know it was time stamped
and they were sort of going in and out
with
then this happened and then that
happened and and putting it in context
because you know
otherwise it doesn't tell a story you
know you just see violent attacks but to
really sort of see it telling a story i
thought the putting together the video
like that was extremely effective and i
think could be very effective to a jury
to a court and and i i really liked that
as sort of a way to tell a story
where i think we're still a little bit
where they need to kind of shore things
up a little bit is again what was donald
trump's connection to all of this like
of course it was terrible right of
course it was bad what happened on on
january 6 and and the breach of the
capital in the insurrection um but i
think they have to lean in more towards
what led up to that and how that was and
how that was seditious conspiracy right
and how what he was doing with you know
i mean of course they said you haven't
you're entitled to file lawsuits that he
is allowed to do but it also shows his
intent it also shows kind of his mindset
and where he was but what was he doing
that was seditious conspiracy you know
and i was sort of googling you know and
looking up sort of
what is seditious conspiracy and and and
you know what is what are the elements
that they would have to prove and it's
it's an agreement by two or more persons
to act with the intention
to excite hatred or contempt against
persons
or institutions of state okay so there's
no doubt that that certain people like
the oath keepers and all those people
there's no doubt they
are guilty of seditious conspiracy but
what was donald trump doing
in that in you know to do that like it
and going silent it's it's going to be
interesting how they're going to prove
that his silence was actually action
because you know normally when you prove
a case like this you prove what
someone's action is you know you prove
sort of what they do
and you know they told people to do
things they said go you know hang mike
pence go stop the counting and the
certification of the electoral votes
instead what he did is he went silent
and people were begging him to stop it
and he didn't and they're going to have
to show that he had knowledge of what
was happening which is clear that he did
right because he was watching it on tv
right next to the oval office that he
had the intent to do it which i think
they're going to be able to show with
all the events leading up to
the insurrection right and the fact that
he all the all the statements he's made
and the tweeting and justification etc i
think they'll be able to prove that but
then they have to show that he acted
right and and
i also think they might have to show if
they re rely on the fact that he had to
call them off and he didn't that he had
a duty and i think they'll be okay with
that because he is a commander-in-chief
right so he was in charge of the
military the national guard the people
that could stop this and he didn't call
them in but i think that there's a
chance that they might have to prove
that he had a duty to stop this so
everything else well so i that's a good
point but i think it could be not just
that he didn't do anything but his
intent to not do it specifically
in action right not what he did but what
he intentionally didn't do that set
these things in the motion and what his
what his intent was behind those things
that he was intentionally not doing is
that is that fair to say because i mean
we see these text messages coming to him
so
to me the clear cut case is in georgia
right the secondary state calls the
secretary of state and he says find the
the votes whatever look under your
mattress
exactly to me that's an easy
open and shut case to me that is the
case that needs to be made and you need
to do period full stop this other case i
think you can do it and i think they're
going to do it but you know i was hoping
for something a little more
um a little more you have to you have to
do a lot of sort of um gymnastics to get
from point a to point b
because he you know he sort of does this
this thing you know that he deflects
well i think you well
i was going to say i think karen brought
up a good point earlier about uh you
know having knowledge of this happening
right you had people outside chanting
hang mike pence and we just find out i
think believe this this past week we
find out from pence's uh chief of staff
but also the fact that
trump was okay with the idea that
hanging pence was a possibility
like the fact that we live in that
reality now right but for a criminal cr
prosecution right you know you might be
okay with something that doesn't make
you guilty of it you have to also
be a part of it right and so that's why
i keep going back to the legal elements
of what they'll have to prove to because
look there's many there's multiple goals
here one is to convince the hearts and
minds of the public so he doesn't get
reelected but another is to prosecute
him and so right now i am just looking
at the prosecution i love this guy by
the way i'm gonna i'm gonna bring in
texas paul real quick to get his
reaction uh texas paul how are you
um i i i wanna see what your reaction
was to some of the video at the end um
because i know it's kind of bone
chilling but what how did you feel about
that um
that video that they showed
i'm mad as hell i i just every time i
watch it i just you know
chairman thompson talked about the will
of the people republicans don't give a
[ __ ] about the will of the people they
care about what they want and that's it
these selfish could you live with
yourself if you had been at the capitol
and done that could you live with
yourself i'm kidding and that's and
that's the thing is they've always
framed it up as a tourist visit and i
appreciate you being mad as hell because
we need to continue that way and it
looks like the it looks like the uh uh
it's going to continue here so i'll give
you the last 30 seconds here paul i
can't hear i just want to i want to
throw this at you they had a documentary
filmmaker there to to to film this they
expected resistance
they thought that they were going to
have
the case to make that we lefties showed
up and they had to put us down
you know they they really thought that i
think that was because
pence had already communicated to trump
that he was not going to overturn this
election right if you remember the
conversation he had with dan quayle he
had made this decision right he was not
going to overturn this for trump trump
knew this when he gave that speech
and you know the the proud was that this
was their last roll of the dice and we
did not show up so all they got was
hours and hours of footage i've said
this before but i really believe that
you talk about the meeting prior to on
january 5th
that's how they get to trump because
this i believe 100 percent that the
people that they're indicting are
flipping like cirque the freaking soleil
i really believe that i mean
karen being a former prosecutor i'm sure
she would agree with that we're going to
go back to the hearing here and thank
you for joining us for that commentary
um everyone i really appreciate you
hanging with us
i'm glad to have you
we'll see you at the end of the hearing
karen are you going to stick around for
the end of the hearing as well yeah i'm
here absolutely well we're going to
we're going to shuffle back in here
thank you guys we'll talk to you very
soon um gabe yeah as as we wait for
thompson here um he's got cable back in
um here we go right on cue let's go
right back to it
be in order
without objection and with
with that the committee stands adjoined
so there we have the very first
meeting
and hearing
uh we have gabe sanchez and
karen agnipolo with us
from legal af
sorry sorry to bring you up on camera so
quick there uh
i just uh i'm just i'm just trying to um
get to see who we have here afterwards
um karen what was some of your take from
the witness testimony
in particular about the proud boys i
felt like um
it almost
it almost felt like uh the filmmaker was
a little standoffish about some of the
evidence that he had i don't know that's
what it felt like to me at some point
he said something about i'm here by
subpoena
yeah it's funny you should mention that
so i don't and i wrote that down i
wanted to explain to people why he said
that
so
that's something a witness can either
voluntarily come and testify or they can
come via subpoena and sometimes
witnesses will say that out loud or want
that to be known out loud sometimes
people come by subpoena and you don't
know they just they don't mention it but
but he clearly
the documentary filmmaker wanted it to
be known that he was here via subpoena
meaning he wasn't there voluntarily and
the reason he said that i think you know
there's a couple of reasons why he
probably said that number one
he's a journalist and and journalists
don't typically uh you know they they
typically have sort of this privilege
where they don't reveal their sources
they don't reveal confidential
information and so i'm sure just partly
to protect the fact that that that sort
of
relationship
and credibility the other is i think he
might frankly and this is just me
guessing but i think he might be a
little afraid of these guys you know i
don't know what he was saying to them to
get himself embedded in them you know he
was right doing a documentary and now
that he's kind of testifying against
them at least if it were me i'd be
afraid of them and i'd want to be say
out loud guess what i'm here by force
i'm not here because i want to i think a
third reason also is to protect his
objectivity if he's later called it a
criminal trial again he doesn't have an
agenda by being hereby
by subpoena is different than coming
forward voluntarily because if you're
coming forward voluntarily you want to
you want to be helpful to one side or
the other and this way he's sort of his
his objectivity and his um
kind of you know lack of bias i just a
journalist i'm just a documentarian is
protected by saying i'm here because you
know i was given a subpoena i don't have
an agenda one way or another so so i
think that's what you picked up on and
those were the reasons i think he wanted
it to be uh known that um
that he was subpoenaed to be there
i'm gonna i'm gonna pull uh texas paul
in again too and see what his take was
on some of the witness testimony texas
paul um
give the mightiest mighty the texas paul
take on on some of the witness testimony
i believe you were kind of upset about
the video
um near the near the end of the first
part where we seen the violence and it
wasn't a tourist
they weren't taking a tour of the
capital these are domestic terrorists it
was violence they were intending to
overthrow the government of the united
states uh usurped the will of the people
and an hour vote
that we
voted for a president united states and
the state certified that vote
what did you make of the testimony of
the police officer that was there on the
front line
it was it was incredibly compelling i
mean she you could just
you could feel what she was feeling when
she was saying it i mean there was no
question and
you know so many people just saw it as a
little bit of pushing and shoving
because you know you get
i don't mean to knock the media but the
media is not very good at really showing
what's really going on down there and
when you see those clips and you see
just how violent it was even before they
had crossed through all the barricades
you know it and you could just see in
her face
when they asked her hey when chairman
thompson asked her
what stands out in your mind what do you
remember and you could just see when she
looked up you could see her eyes go to
that recall portion of her brain and she
was seeing it again you know that that's
really got me but you know
the the
when they were talking to everybody that
had been but had pled guilty the one
statement that got me
after everything trump has done for us
what the hell did he do for anybody i i
i can't i can't even give you one thing
it it
it really it really is um crazy that
they're still defending
um
no i think every i think i think one two
three four all of us are all sitting
here holding our tongue thinking the
exact same thing yeah what's that
[ __ ] that's what he did right he
left i mean he did he didn't unleash he
did on
[ __ ] that's what he did and he
unleashed them on on our country and on
our democracy and i think um you know
everyone has the right to be pissed uh
like texas paul and and if you can if
you'll stay with us here um go ahead no
go ahead go ahead paul i don't want her
to leave before i get to saying karen
this has been amazing i hope i get to
hear
no no stay with us stay with us
don't leave i'm gonna i'm gonna bring in
i'm gonna bring in um a couple of fellas
you might you might know uh hang around
with us uh kfa and paul um i'm gonna
bring you right back um me and gabe are
gonna bring up uh
uh two guys that you might you might
know
um how are you how are you fellas
doing well first i i gotta say you guys
been ben can't work has been to know how
to work
the lawyer ben never knows technology
ben doesn't know how to work on what
he's doing then he's on mute ben yeah
well i mean you know he's there he's
just silently collecting his thoughts
you gotta unmute the mic before you
speak better
hearing talk about the hearing fellas
brett you were going to say that tony
and gabe first i want to commend the
production here tony and gabe incredible
job this is the first of its kind midas
media network live stream of an event of
the scale we of course did the marjorie
taylor green hearings which were a huge
success and got us into live streaming
these events and now we are so proud and
honored to bring everybody in the midas
mighty and beyond hopefully we got a few
new midas mighty converts this week into
the midas touch family to watch these
live events so tony don't break too much
don't break too much on gabe you're
gonna give him a huge hit texas kfa
david bender michael cohen politics girl
i mean how do you get bigger than this
night here i sort of say the testimony
was really
really riveting i thought you know it
brings to mind everything that we all
witnessed that day i mean i don't think
anything was too
shocking or surprising because we all
lived through it uh and it's a reminder
of all the things we live through and i
think all that footage though the new
footage especially when you see people
in depositions when you see people in
this testimony where they're under oath
like ivanka trump throwing her father
under the bus
taking dead bars outside
everyone's a big ass bus dude
ivanka out of the will of the world oh
oh she's definitely well they've got
they've got yeah they've got jared's two
billion so they're good to go you know
well yeah it happens you know i i want
to give ben time to talk but and jordy
never gets the talk ever he's over there
with the bullet pop
just like i said jordy what was what was
the part that stood out to you the most
well that's the part of ivanka ivankava
strongly disavowing her father
that moment will stand out i mean she
she's cut from the trust hands down you
know i think she cleared her name by
doing so
you know she obviously still played a
tremendous role in all of this
but going directly against the family
like that they'll be ripples the family
i like how you said the family like like
it's a mop
i just want to say there's one quote
that i think is going to stand the test
of time here i think there's going to be
one quote from this opening night of
hearings and that's going to
last beyond all the hearings and that's
liz cheney directing a message at her
republican colleagues and saying there
will come a day when donald trump is
gone but your dishonor
will remain i think that is everything
that needed to be said to them will they
change not one bit because they are
dishonorable disgusting despicable
people that would rather see this
country fall to fascism and go in the
hands of donald trump against the will
of the voters than do what is right and
abide by our constitution i i think
you're right and you know ben what do
you think do you think brett is going to
be able to take that clip that he just
said that quote and cut it and make a
video after video after video here do
you think that's the case well i i know
you've been incredibly busy tony and
gabe but we've already cut that clip
okay well
we we were we were making production
pieces on the fly well we we like the me
me and not the mouse in my pocket gabe
and the mouse in his pocket were making
uh production pieces as we were going
but it was working out well but do you
think that you think that's the clip or
is there something else that stands out
to you i thought that entire liz cheney
opening remark was very very special
right i think benny thompson did a
really good job as well but really liz
cheney's opening was a methodical
takedown
surgical it had the clips interspersed
throughout it and i thought the clips
were probably the most effective part
going back to what we said earlier you
know and each of the personalities kind
of showed i mean just even watching
jared kushner up there and this was a
subtle part about kushner's uh testimony
where he was basically one he looked
like a total tool when he was uh
testifying he is because he was talking
about and then used much stronger
language in the text to me
when we were talking about but here's
what he said he was he claims he was
busy doing at the time too busy to uh to
care about it he was too busy focusing
on probably other criminal activity
which was the pardon scheme where they
were basically
using the white house to get bought off
to then give people pardons in exchange
for significant amounts of money and and
know what he said too he called you know
the top white house officials
complaining that trump was violating the
law he called them whining and said it
sounded like they were just whiny people
like whiny people these were people
speaking up against some of the most
major violations of the law and as you
unpeel the layers here and this is what
we were talking about in our text
message chain you know this mega group
is such a cult
and to see that cult behavior but then
to see some little ripples of hope there
at the end where some of those members
of the cult on the video started talking
about how they felt betrayed how they
said that they thought that donald trump
was going to be storming the capitol
with them and they felt that they were
thrown under the bus so i think we're
going to be hearing more about that but
for today's purposes the goal was to set
this thing up about what was going to
happen what the events that are going to
unfold and that's and that's what they
did a really good job at that one final
thing i want to mention to all the
people listening which they may not know
about the production but we have our own
cameras in there so um what tries to
differentiate this stream the high
production value that tony and gabe
bring but that this is licensed
proprietary footage that is midas
footage and so we proudly put the midas
logo on there because the footage that
you saw was taken by a mice's lightest
mice midas licensed camera there and
we're going to bring you all that
proprietary information as we continue
to build this network out and build the
network out that's focused on really one
thing pro democracy speaking of that i
think i think part of this is going to
go on directories or all of it or
something like that so be looking for
that um in your directories are you guys
posting as might as touch podcast since
this kind of got on yours i know we plan
on but we plan on cutting some of it and
posting some of it on ours it's like the
best of the week we normally do a best
of the week on saturday so we plan on
doing some of that but you guys plan on
putting it on directories is that right
for people this will live as the midas
touch podcast on the
what day is it today on the friday
morning edition we'll post it as soon as
we get the audio from you tony after
this yeah yeah we'll post it on the
podcast feed so that people could listen
to all the commentary and the entire
unedited january 6th hearings the
opening night um i want everybody to be
able to look at that of course you will
be able to replay this video right here
on youtube at any time on demand i want
to make sure everybody who's watching
right now also subscribes to our channel
because this is not going to be the only
hearing that we broadcast we'll be
broadcasting every single hearing of the
january 6 committee as well as other
content reaction videos from incredible
content creators just like texas paul
just like kfa david bender lee mcgowan
politics girl michael popock everybody
you name it you can find them all on the
midas touch media network right here on
our youtube channel
well speaking of that why don't you go
over and subscribe to the tony michael's
podcast because it's crying out loud you
got to go over there and
check that out just type in the tony
michaels podcast when you go over to
youtube um so download download the
episode do not forget to download this
episode it's super important apple
spotify wherever you get your your
podcast go check that out um you know
you brought up a few names there but i
have a few people waiting did you fellas
want to stick around do you see you want
to ha what kind of round table this uh
this production tool will do here you
want to you want to say as much as i
want to see that i want to highlight
some of the other great uh creators okay
well they didn't want you in here
anyways
go go go back in your text chain and and
talk somewhere else no we appreciate you
having you and thanks thanks thanks guys
if you guys want to stick around and
talk let's talk i just want to say one
more thing before we get out of here i
want to let everybody know the current
tentative schedule of the january 6th
hearing so you know where to tune in
when to tune in the next hearing is
going to be june 13th that's monday at
10 a.m so be back here monday at 10 a.m
probably a little bit before um 10 a.m
that's on the midas touch youtube
channel the next one will be june 15th
at 10 a.m june 16th at 10 a.m june 21st
at 10 a.m finishing up with a prime time
hearing on june 23rd so that is the
schedule get ready marketing your
calendars and you'll be able to watch it
right here on the minus media network
jordy you got a couple words you got a
couple words yeah i see a couple
comments on this shirt that i'm wearing
uh right now and i just wanted to let
everyone know that they could pick this
one up in particular at
store.minustouch.com
what you got here it says uh thoughts
and prayers x out and instead policy and
change and the cool thing about this is
a certain amount of profits from this
shirt are actually going to go to mom's
demand action
uh so check out
store.midastouch.com tonight check this
out good call let's join on a little
secret if you use the code justice
tonight on store.midastouch.com you'll
get ten percent off all merch that's ten
percent
all merch promo code we have the best
production team on the planet i mean
give me a break
on that note let's get let some of our
creators in here once again thank you to
everybody who's participating thank you
for giving us thank you thank you thank
you
i can't leave any i can't leave any uh
any stream without saying shout out to
the midas mighty
thank you very much fellas thank you
very much uh gabe i think i think what
we should do is we should bring in uh
we've got michael popock waiting we've
got lee mcgowan politics girl waiting um
we got a few others i've got david
bender here as well um david i want to
give you a chance to say a few things
then we'll bring in politics girl here
um what was your overall take your your
mic's muted there if you could unm your
mic that would be
you got it there got it there we go
there we go
all right well it happened uh to witness
so i'm i'm doing it in honor uh of what
we saw tonight which was truly
astounding
this was the narrative and i think we
talked about it coming into the
hearing just before began they were
going to tell a story
we've begun down that path and you
cannot
come into it without
just getting gripped
they got into the footage when they saw
it and there was a clock again what we
talked about
tick tock right tick tocking it down you
go right through it and each time they
put the time on and there's important
thing to note the proud boys were there
way before trump spoke they were there
10 in the morning 10 30 morning they
were taking photos
exactly long before this this was
planned out they knew what they were
doing but let me let me give you one
immediate takeaway because i think we're
going to see this this is the
questioning that's coming particularly
from liz cheney but from chairman
thompson as well
this is all about
what did the president not know
and not do
and when did he not do it he knew
actually all of it but what did he not
do and there's so many moments
think about what they said
when the officer was holding the line
when she fell back in and became
unconscious her time and then she got up
and she saw everyone bleeding
and people
throwing up
what was donald trump doing
what was he doing he was watching
television and egging it on
he was fooled by it he couldn't
understand why everyone else wasn't
thrilled by it what did he not do and
when did he not do it he didn't do
anything
when she was lying on the ground
and that's the dots that are going to be
connected the proud boys are going to
we'll connect it by saying he let us
down we saw that at the end he didn't
come with us of course he wouldn't he's
a coward he didn't go to war either yeah
this is who this man is right so
the the thing the last segment which
talked about a series of
people who are either convicted
or awaiting trial
all of them talking about how they felt
called to
serve their president he only asked one
thing of me
to come to washington i gave him my vote
i had to do that for him
and and all i could think of is
ask not what your president can do for
you but what you can do for your
president
uh and that is who donald trump is what
do you do for me right right
yeah very very selfish mentality that's
trumpism don't you agree that's trumpism
well i mean that's that's the trump
derangement syndrome is really what it
is whereas i'll i'll put down two
mortgages for my house to make sure that
i can keep making the recurring payments
for your trump fund no that's what it is
the grift is real i'm going to bring in
more of our panel here let's see if we
can get a round table going here uh we
got politics girl we got michael popock
we got karen agnipolo texas paul look at
this look at this round table this is
like the avengers of uh it is
right here
the midas mighty avengers is that right
uh lee lee what was your take um because
i really want to get
what you thought about some of the
witness testimony because i believe you
know paul actually uh said it the police
officer some of her testimony was almost
chilling at some points just because you
really felt what she was really thinking
there but also the the filmmaker you
know and tell us what you thought about
some of the witness testimony
well i think you know usually in this
kind of situation i don't like to talk
right off the top of my head because i'm
someone that likes to absorb things
think about what they did and then come
up with a conclusion that's kind of how
my brain works but um
i will say especially speaking to kfa's
point that she was a little bit
concerned that hiring a professional
producer to do this
would make it too showy too perfect too
clean too much like a presentation and i
thought that the whole thing they got
the tone exactly right it's um
it's not super showy you can tell that
they hired a producer when you look at
those videos because they're so well
done they've got the timelines they've
got the video footage at the same time
that trump's tweeting something with the
voiceover of things that were happening
simultaneously so they're telling a
beautiful story but they've clearly
hired a story producer rather than a
producer producer to make it showy and
perfect the tone was professional and
stayed and i saw someone when it first
started and they said pick up the energy
and i thought no don't pick up the
energy this is exactly the energy
because this is a congressional hearing
about something incredibly serious and i
think that that's the thing that struck
me the most it was a reminder of what a
horror that day was and the humanity of
the people that were involved and this
idea that here's this officer and i
think she said at one point like she
looked up and it was carnage it was
chaos it was
war it was something you see in a movie
and she said i'm not combat trained you
know this is hours of hand-to-hand
combat to defend our capital from its
own citizens
and
i don't know how you can listen to that
i mean i felt weepy i thought can i get
back on this screen like i
i'm
horrified by
how far our country has fallen and
how
long an entire group of people have
allowed us to try and sweep this under
the rug
and this is essential what we're
watching it's essential
so i uh i think i think you're right in
those aspects but i'm gonna go to our
anchor down there at the bottom uh the
foundation here for michael popock
because i know he's very optimistic
about our democracy uh i've listened to
michael talk about the legal issues he
is he's very he's very optimistic about
our demand am i wrong am i wrong i think
i'm good here um
give us give us what your angle is and
what you took away from not because we
haven't we haven't spoke to you tonight
but
not just the witness testimony but in
the very beginning about the
you know just actually laying out what
happened and i thought the videos that
they produced um laying out when they
laid siege on the capitol was absolutely
gut-wrenching so what was what was your
take
that's going to be the takeaway i agree
with lee and i agree with karen
that the the production values were less
concerning to me that they hired a
former abc news or whatever he was or
producer
the content that they had
from a year of investigation
the thousand interviews the hundreds of
thousands of pieces of evidence most of
which
even the pundits sitting around here
have not seen
we just got a very very small percentage
of it now the takeaway is going to be
the visceral reaction of the testimony
of the police officer
battling for her life to protect
democracy but for me and this goes to
what you and i talked about earlier
before this started
that's not the takeaway for me the
takeaway for me is this we haven't even
heard all seven legs of the stool it's
this it's the things that cheney said
about seven part conspiracy
with donald trump at the center hub
of all of those spokes we talked about
it earlier on on your show of what some
of those were
it's the you it's it's the it's trying
to corrupt the department of justice
through using clark
to be his henchman in the in the waning
moments of the trump presidency and to
take after bill barr walked out the door
elvis left the building and left it
behind for you know
rosen and donahue to try to be the
adults in the room but the department of
justice if if if it was successfully
corrupted by trump
would have in a devastating fashion
led potentially to the overthrow of the
government and and we heard cheney lay
out that evidence you have department of
justice being attacked and corrupted by
donald trump you have the
uh we haven't even gotten there yet we
have eastman
and the fake electors and the and the
state legislators and the mike pence
strategy that we've only heard a little
bit about with navarro we have the
lawsuits
the 60 lawsuits led by rudy giuliani and
powell and jenna ellis
and these were not even though we
covered them like they were individual
events already the jan six committee i
think is presenting this as a coherent
cohesive
conspiracy with donald trump as one of
the lead co-conspirators and there's
multiple and karen can talk more about
this as her years of prosecutors there's
multiple
nested and nestled conspiracies within
the conspiracy
there's there's eastman and trump
related to the fake electors and to the
uh and to the mike pence strategy
there's the
um clark and trump and the overthrow
attempted overthrow of the department of
justice and knocking over the department
of justice in order to execute his plan
when that didn't work it's the lawsuits
and the conspiracy with giuliani and the
rest when that didn't work
let's throw proud boys oath keepers and
a bunch of other people who have been
completely fomented
by trump both at the time of the
election all leading up to gen 6 and
even before the election he i mean we
talked about this earlier trump has
complained about fraud in the election
starting with the iowa caucus and ted
cruz that ted cruz stole the iowa caucus
he he came out and said even in
primaries that he won that if he lost it
had to be because of fraud and that was
with republicans against other
republicans he was never going to go
away quietly and peacefully transition
power
that's from the very beginning and then
he blows the dog whistles of violence
in the way he tweets at the moment that
he tweets because if anybody thinks he's
not a master of media at the moment
and using twitter and social he knows
when he can flame discontent he knows
when he can quell it and he made those
decisions as david bender said earlier
he made those decisions to act or not
act intentionally and all of those
things including things like evidence
that has now been hidden which shows
criminal mind and criminal intent where
are the 300 minutes
of of telephone logs from jan 6 why are
they missing
that's that's the acts of a criminal
that's not the act of somebody that has
nothing to hide somebody who has nothing
to hide cooperates with the jan six
committee cooperates with the impaneling
of a blue ribbon panel
people
listen one of his people
donald trump even said if you plea the
fifth do you remember him saying this if
you plead the faith you're guilty you're
guilty and and and i mean he's done it
time and time and time and time again
and he'll continue to do it so i i do
want to go because i like your point
about um karen knowing the prosecution
side of this um because i want to hear
because some of those testimony tapes
they seem pretty compelling in the video
evidence as well like we've seen bill
barr we've seen ivanka trump we've seen
jared kushner we've seen jason miller
even now he had a mask the thumb had a
mask on but he kind of looked like um a
thumb version of bane but jason miller
gave testimony so karen tell us a little
bit about how compelling those tapes
were of the testimony
looking at it from a prosecutor's
standpoint i mean
is that
is that something or is that nothing
so i think that what's really
interesting here is there are certain
aspects of this case that are extremely
uh kind of
lock solid you know easy to prosecute
like the pro like they have proven
beyond a reasonable doubt that the proud
boys and the oath keepers
are basically organized criminals of the
hierarchy of structure and you know what
they did that day but but this is really
this isn't just about january 6. that's
sort of the culmination of it all but i
what everyone's saying and what popock
just said is that this is really about
so much that what a conspiracy that
spans for a very long period of time
and there's so much evidence that points
to this this dramatic moment where this
is great video
and you've got this great testimony it
was really chilling but so much of this
is going to be putting together little
pieces you know building the brick wall
if you will of of guilt you know to show
that all of these things are
interconnected and that donald trump is
is guilty of a crime and i think what
what's really interesting about this
case and what i think is unprecedented
is prosecutors usually are the ones who
build their cases for them you know you
sit there and you comb through millions
of pieces of evidence and videos and
text messages i have never seen a case
that is so well built by so many people
i mean you've got the 104 page brooks
brookings institute report that is a
road map
to who committed what crime when and how
to prosecute it you've got the judge
clark in california eastman
uh decision
where that was a a discovery dispute and
whether they had to he had to turn over
documents um
and and the judge was like well let me
let me explain to you uh why it was more
likely than not that donald trump
committed these crimes and laid it out
in in many many many pages of a crime
you've got this hearing you've got liz
cheney who said there's a seven there's
seven reasons or seven legs to the stool
as i think you said of of how this is a
criminal conspiracy i mean it's like
people are spoon feeding the department
of justice because this is complicated
it's not
you know it is not kind of a super
simple one incident event you know you
shoot someone and there's murder you
know that's an one incident event this
is a very complex series of facts that
need to be woven together and i think
the evidence today was was brilliant you
know i thought the videos put together
with the time stamps really helped tell
a narrative and tell a story i thought
you know but you really need evidence
you need testimony i thought officer
edwards was just what a what an
incredible witness she is i mean you
know we were slipping in people's blood
while we were trying to what an image
i mean what an image and you know and i
think as david said you you i think it
was or paul i can't remember which one
of you said it how you could tell when
when she sort of went into the
you know she was really going back to um
what happened you know you could just
see this like that she was reliving it
and and that's the kind of thing and
ivanka you know was just i thought it
was going to be a very powerful witness
bill barr you know he is going to be a
very powerful witness so you know the i
think they're really sort of painting a
picture and i agree with lee i thought
this was not you know my fear that this
was going to be over produced and you
know i thought it struck the right
balance it was not over produced it was
you know this is just sort of what it is
and people kind of and it had the ring
of truth so i i really applaud them for
what they have done i thought their
opening remarks were excellent but i i
really think prosecutors you know the
road maps are there if they want to
follow them you know i keep thinking in
georgia just just do that one because
that is sort of a simple one you know
right that's an easy slam dunk and
that's right
but you know just it's it's there it's
just really it's just time to do it
right so so i want to go to uh texas
paul you brought up something paul said
and and uh paul i i want you to express
because you're so good at it uh to
express you know we're talking about
this well-produced evidence but this
evidence is designed to get the
information to americans right um karen
would love for prosecutors to take this
information and and prosecute on it but
the american people are really supposed
to absolutely um digest this information
and not just this hearing but the
continued hearings so tell us what you
think about the average american person
like what do you think they should see
and what kind of what kind of anger do
you think they should have that these
people were really trying to tear down
our democracy that was their goal and
not just the people who marched on the
capitol but the people who sent them
there the people who stoked that fire i
mean give us give us that texas paul
take on how we were supposed to view
this information that we
have well i'll tell you i'll start right
here and right now with what's going on
right now as we speak if you look over
at the chat comments
there are people that sat through this
the entire time watch that evidence and
they still
are trolling for donald trump right
still
still just trolls in the comments
trolling for donald trump right now
and i i have to tell you it's just
amazing to me that anybody could sit
through this i mean this is day one
but sit through this and and you know
how many people told donald trump what
was it miller it was our pardon me it
was it was bar it was rosen it was uh
meadows everybody told donald trump
well before he stoked all this up
there's nothing there with the the
statement was there's no there there but
from meadows you know
they knew they had nothing this was a
completely fabricated coupe and ever
that's what i want every american to
take away from this is there's no doubt
trump couldn't believe that he really
had an election stolen from him
everyone with any credibility had looked
at this
and said and even people without
credibility like bill barr
you know that this was his hinchman went
to him and told him
boss
we got to go you know and and he still
pushed it
he still pushed it right you know and
and that's what makes this so
unforgivable
you know for people like that to still
be in the comments and trolling if you
think that you don't have to get your
ass out and vote
i you are out of your damn mind every
single vote in this midterm counts
because if people like that get power
again
our democracy is gone mike i i applaud i
absolutely of
mike popock i applaud your optimism i
really do but i'm telling you if they
get their hands on the wheels of power
again there will not be you know they
know millie stopped him when trump said
hey go shoot protesters
and general milly stop them
they will not make that mistake again
right they will not make these same
mistakes again well the one thing i
really have to be hot yeah
the one thing i'm encouraged about paul
is that um
even people
around him were talking about the 25th
amendment and taking trump out in the
waning days they knew they knew and
there were people that quit in protest
but in retrospect many of those people
looking back may have wanted to stay
and get the votes up to take that man
out i've hey uh tony i got a question
yeah
for the panel um i have my own thought
about this
why do you think ivanka trump
was played
day one
hour one of the presentations what let's
go to dave yeah why why because it's not
the most it's not the most critical
piece of evidence that they could have
presented but what why did they do it
that's an easy one because we'll see
that clip over and over again
they knew and this was discussed uh
do you save
uh ivanka do you save
jared do you save anyone else pat salone
if he agrees you save him for the end or
do you sprinkle them throughout so that
we can have and this is what's going to
happen over this weekend
uh my inbox is already being flooded
with the clips that have been cut
and and you guys are doing it as well
that we're all going to see and they're
going to be on
you couldn't watch this without knowing
the parts that we're going to see again
and again and again there's one thing
sadly i've got to go because i've got to
start very early and do all of this but
i i do want to
note something that lee said
uh there's a word that you uh you
hit on which came out of her testimony
came out of
officer edward's testimony about
carnage
and i couldn't help but remember that
this president
was sworn in
having given a speech about ending
american carnage
that was donald trump's inaugural
and what is his what will he be
remembered for
he's going to be remembered for creating
carnage
that's what this
next five set of hearings is going to
show us
that he created that carnage he might as
well have been there he was as i said
going in if you missed it let me say it
again he's a coward
he would never have physically been
there because he'd be afraid of it
that's why he didn't go to vietnam
but let's be clear
he created this carnage
and he was happy it was happening and
all of that is going to be the narrative
that we're going to see over these next
five hearings so i agree with texas paul
everyone's going to vote but they got to
vote with a remote
they've got a vote over these next five
hearings they've gotta watch this
everybody's gotta watch anyone you talk
to
you've gotta make them what is the word
fomo
that they are missing out if they don't
see the rest of these hearings and we've
got to tell them that over this weekend
going into monday because this has got
to build
and that's what that's my message is
these hearings are going to tell us what
happens to our democracy
and i honestly believe that we have a
chance
at resetting the narrative uh what they
did tonight was a great great start
and i got to thank you guys a pleasure
to be here
thank you for coming on the show yeah
thanks for joining us david and
always come back
for these other hearings if you have
time we'd love to have you
else we can get in by the way eric
swalwell is with the speaker right now
oh okay
we thought we might we thought we might
be able to get arrogant
we'll try and get him for for next week
but he's fine speaker pelosi uh
protecting her i think from the crowd
thank you all thank you thank you very
much david you have a good one
um so everybody um and popock posed the
question
so i guess maybe we should go around lee
do you want to take um uh pop's question
there yeah i wanted to hear from lee on
that one actually yeah i figured that's
i didn't know it who who i didn't know
exactly who he was appoint your mike i
didn't know exactly who
who um who he was pointing it to but it
seemed like he might have been pointing
it towards uh politics girl lee mcgowan
well you know like i said i like to
figure things out but my guess would be
uh very much what david said which is
basically they did it on purpose to
sprinkle it in to keep us interested
from day one to make us tell our friends
to watch it this is all important stuff
this is
uh just good advertising but also i mean
in my opinion and i know nothing i don't
know the inner workings of donald
trump's mind but the one child he really
truly cares about and cares about the
opinion of and cares about how he's
perceived by and cares about how she
perceives him
is ivanka this is the person he cares
about most in the world aside from
himself and i think that
he is a man who
is a
target narcissist absolutely it's all
about what he can do what he can do if
there is one other person in the world
and to see her
take
the narrative that he knew all along
that he didn't win that she believed
barr which is what they cut you know she
said i believe bar i trust bar it says
my father was lying
and we knew it right and that's a stick
in his craw and if you want to see
someone melt down
that's the way to do it yeah and i
thought
lee i thought you're exactly right i
thought it was an f you to donald trump
right
the point it proved the point of
knowledge
so poignantly with his favorite child
yeah i mean if you if you yeah if you
look at trump right there's there's
certain things that are his kryptonite
right whether you talk about his hands
his hair or his intelligence the number
one on that list
right the lean that he's got the number
one on that list is gonna be ivanka so
if there's any sort of reactionary
response that he has that they want to
get out to potentially comment on
it's going to be used uh ivanka against
them
well also if you have a you know a mob
like mentality you're going to go after
the person that's closest to your dawn
you know and in this case this is an
actual dawn and it's ivanka she's the
one with his ear and you're breaking
apart the family they have to be a
cohesive unit if they're going to tell
this narrative i mean they told us in
this
uh
in the last two hours they had
general milly saying that mark meadows
called him and said we have to kill this
narrative that pence is in charge we
have to spread the narrative that the
president is still in charge and he's
and that's how they look at the whole
world it's a narrative right it's about
it's not about the truth it's not about
it's pride it's always about always
it's about the story they want to tell
and they've been very
very successful at it and it's why
people like me even exist because we
were like where's the opposite side to
all of this narrative and we filled a
vacuum that our side left not filled the
story um and i think like david said
this could be an opportunity to
reset the narrative and if you break
apart the story they're telling and you
start with the closest person to him
that's a pretty pretty good place to
start
karen what do you think about the
the ivanka the ivanka clip there i i
like the ivanka clip i'm i'm a fan of
the ivanka clip but what did you think
what what what do you do you think they
put it in the beginning
um for the reasons that they're saying
or is there something different you're
the one who who handles these things any
litigator knows you lead with your best
evidence you don't certainly don't bury
it so i think for the reasons for the
reasons lee and popock are saying it's
the you know for those reasons it is the
best it's not just what she said but
it's really who said it and how it's
going to be received and so for those
reasons it really does make it their
strongest evidence and it's how you're
going to capture
kind of you know grip everyone's
attention and make them want to come
back so you know you lead with your best
and strongest evidence and i think they
really did that tonight right and and
she was she was very powerful i want
more of that you know i'm sure everybody
else does right well uh paul i gotta ask
you about uh because i have a question
yeah good question you think this is the
first time donald trump is learning that
that's what she said
probably that that's what i don't know
i think i think it's the first time that
he's learning what she said on a public
stage that's right because she might
have said she might have said those
things obviously in private or heard
whispers you know many people are saying
but now it really is
many people are saying right that she
talked behind your back well that was
actually my question to to paul is
do you think there's just like
wheelbarrows full of shitty diapers at
mar-a-lago tonight because of some of
the test
what what i'm trying to speak in a
language that people will understand
here because i know paul speaks in my
language most of the time paul do you
think there's just wheelbarrows of
shitty diapers down there at mar-a-lago
after he heard some of the stuff he
heard not only from ivanka but from the
likes of bill barr and others i mean
what do you think
there's no doubt that cut deep there is
no doubt that cut deep and i will tell
you i've got a slightly different take
on why they did it okay my if my
grocer's last name was cheney i wouldn't
buy an apple from the sun [ __ ] i'm
telling you i wouldn't but i have no
love for liz cheney but she has brought
something to this committee that
republic uh the dem we democrats have
been
sorely needing yeah look at lee she
knows exactly where i'm going with this
this in the end is a political exercise
the doj will do the prosecuting folks
like karen will do the actual fighting
that makes that makes the difference
with the indictments and people going to
jail this in the end is a political
exercise and politics is a knife fight
and believe me they stuck it in trump
tonight and they broke it off with over
with ivanka they really did don't talk
about language i'm telling you i am
telling you this that was pure liz
cheney right there because there i'm
telling you that was killer that was
killer instinct and we need a lot more
of that i guarantee you i
i have to rethink how much i hate liz
cheney i may just
only hate her this much is great
right the enemy of my enemy is my friend
right now right there you go well i i
i've always said that that liz cheney
isn't necessarily you know uh people get
it mixed up that she she may not be
necessarily the perfect person to hold
up as someone who loves democracy
because she's voted against voting
rights just in the last six months so i
mean
to say that she is in this for democracy
i i believe liz janey has uh some other
motives other than just democracy but
for her party to come back to what it
used to be the gop not the gqp the the q
anon crazies the marjorie taylor greens
the lauren boberts the the mo brooks the
gosars just just the absolute craziness
that they have in their party right now
the democracy has to survive it's to
some extent to get that back right and
she probably wants to be the
the king maker there she wants to hold
the throne of the gop um
but you're right in that there's no
better person than darth vader jr
because that's what i call her on my
show darth vader jr because her dad is
darth vader
then to really go after the trump family
and and try to bury trumpism with this
narrative because i think you guys are
right that this is politics because i i
always talk about this on on our show
and gabe knows this is there's politics
and there's policy
and you don't get to set policy unless
you do the politics part and we are in a
knife fight for our democracy we are
fighting against fascism it is an enemy
that will not quit they're not going to
stop until they get what they want
and we have to do the same we have to
fight for our democracy it's super
important um
and i believe everybody on this panel
believes that way
and maybe maybe to some extent you're
right paul
there might be just a drip just a drip
there of liz cheney that believes that
democracy
is the right way even though she may not
be for things like voting rights or
women's bodily autonomy or anything like
that so yeah we have to give it to her
tonight
they all think they can see the future
and what she sees in the future is that
after she's done with them on here
that there will not it's going to be
scorched earth on on the republican side
that that the folks the crazies will
have no cover she's going to burn them
to the ground and she's going to be left
standing i guarantee you she is her
father's daughter she is going to napalm
the [ __ ] out of the republicans you
watch yeah and her father was pure evil
so if she's got any of that in her
hopefully she'll unleash that for the
good she'll take the shotgun out hunter
right maybe they'll go on a hunting trip
i don't know she had the she had one of
the well she had many great lines
tonight but one of them was that donald
trump will know will not be around in
the future but the stain that is on your
reputation will live forever right right
and bret brett my zealous brought that
up um when we were talking to the myself
brothers um lee what was one of the
lines that kind of that kind of stood
out to you one thing that stood out to
me
um and before i 30 is that that when liz
cheney said there were members of
congress in line to get pardons like how
did we just miss that like members of
congress were like hey i want one well i
want one over here like you don't
normally ask for a pardon just you know
because you didn't commit crimes i mean
come on but what what moment stood out
to you is there any specific moment that
stood out to you a specific line that
resonated with you that you're going to
put on your show because i know you're
going to have several of those moments
on your show no i'm i'm doing that uh
the fomo thing that's the next thing i'm
going to do i'm going to do a little
rant on you can't miss can't miss this
because i think it is really essential i
think the gist that really stuck to me
is
they're making it very clear they were
very clear they said it was a coup
attempt that he knew he'd lost that he
deliberately lied that everybody told
him he'd lost that there was no
confusion about that and then he made a
massive effort to spread fraudulent
information to the american people and i
think the thing is is that we're still
living in the result of that that didn't
end on the 6th of january 2021 we still
live
in this
existence where one third of the country
is functioning with fraudulent
information and if we're going to
fix anything we have to
break the narrative that these people
are telling the truth because right
because the coup is still ongoing right
the coup is still ongoing that's kind of
what yeah and
i am well it is and i think the thing is
is that
i can't watch that and not think how
incredibly lucky we got
that there were just enough people that
said no because it seemed like there was
a fair amount of people that were
willing to go along with it and there
was just enough people that were like
you can't do that that's not allowed and
we won't get that opportunity the second
time if they get back in power it will
only be people that say yes so
we can't allow that to happen and that's
the the
impetus people have to have to work to
talk to their friends to discuss this
stuff because when you talk about
politics i say this all the time i mean
a lot of people's eyes glaze over they
don't like it they're bored they don't
want to be interested in it they don't
want to talk about it and unfortunately
they have to so we have to be that
annoying person at the dining room table
we have to be that person at dinner we
have to be that person that says y'all
you watching this because
this is this is our country's going one
of two directions right
and we have to push it in the right one
i agree with you i got i got a question
yep by show of hands if somebody had
told you
uh you know two years ago that mike
pence would be the person that stood up
and did the right thing
and saved our democracy
he would have got just laughed in that
person's face you some [ __ ] um
i would
i would have voted for him i would have
voted for him to get in the car and get
away from the capitol right yeah right
that is that is surprising you know pope
bach mentioning that um i i think that
is surprising that he didn't scurry away
um as fast as he could
and i don't know if it was mark short
and maybe we'll find this out because i
think that's a key piece of evidence
here that really in the intent of donald
trump like what what was mark short and
and mike pence saying in that parking
garage that wasn't allowing him to go i
trust the secret service and i should
run away i mean what's your thoughts on
that do you think we'll see because
you've read that 200 page i mean you've
read period to period on that thing so
does that thing say anything about mike
pence and what the fly on his head saw
in that parking garage
yeah i think it well okay well i think
it's it's late i gotta i gotta make some
jokes i think i think it was he realized
that his sole purpose in being
the president pro tempore of the senate
and vice president at the time of the
counting was to certify that election
and that if if i think at that moment it
must have dawned on him that he was
being whisked away as part of that
conspiracy and he had he had to just
listen you either believe in the
constitution and the oath of office that
benny thompson talks so eloquently about
to open the session or you don't and
regardless of your politics
you are either a defender an oath keeper
of the truest sense of the constitution
or you are not and say what you want
about mike pence or say what we would
have said about liz cheney before all
this happened right but they believe in
the constitution and their role under it
and the and the oath they took to
support defendant i think you're right
and i think that's the key here is
because
without the constitution and really if
you think about if what they wanted to
have happen right if if trump and his
allies what they wanted to have happened
that they would have happened um the
entire country would have fell apart you
know i mean if you start to think about
the foundation the absolute foundation
that that document is because it's not
just a [ __ ] piece of paper i mean and
it's not just an idea it is the absolute
foundation and principle of of the rule
of law and our country i mean if you
take away the app the ability of a
president to have to follow the
constitution
he or she can do whatever the hell they
want i mean who would if we wouldn't
have been able to stop donald trump
from overturning the constitution and
taking away our vote from us that day
what is to stop him from from taking
away statehoods what's to stop him to
say you know i don't like that state
constitution i don't like that state
constitution i don't like this court i
don't like that court the hell with this
the hell with that the hell with the
writing a check to these folks in this
part of the country the hell with the
highways in this part of the i mean
what's to stop him from doing that and
watch desantis
you're watching it watch the santas in
the little lab blueprint in the
blueprint without the us constitution as
a guard rail and watch what he's doing
right right well and i mean that that
may be the model that desantis is trying
to show over hey because i think that's
really what desantis you know to your to
your point is is he's trying to say hey
i want to i want to make make the united
states florida you know i want to you
know do that to the whole united states
um i want to go to my co-host here and
because he's worked hard on this
production and i want to get his
thoughts on the entirety of
the hearing from front to back because
we were kind of making some graphics and
doing some things on the fly but he was
paying attention um so what what was the
thing that stood out to you gabe that
really
drives home the message that the
constitution is the most important part
of this and that's what they wanted to
you know excuse the language [ __ ] on
because that's literally what they did
in the capital well i mean i think the
first half with the with the depositions
were good to set up you know even people
within the inner circle of trump thought
that you know he was
he was a loser right they all admitted
the reality that he didn't win the
election
and to show those things i think was a
good start right and i'm hoping that
they'll continue during the next
uh
morning
hearings that we have in the upcoming
couple of weeks but i think the parts
that were most effective and i think we
touched on it before is is the
testimonies that were given either from
the documentary filmmaker but also
especially the capitol police officer
right
the the group that the right exclaims in
in their patriotic roar that they love
to back the blue
are willing to
[ __ ] on
those
that they want to protect us right those
that are there at the capitol to protect
democracy
they said nah screw it yeah we're gonna
we're gonna push you down we're gonna do
this we're gonna we're gonna do very
vile things against you and i think that
testimony that she gave
was so impactful and i think we needed
to hear that right because it's not the
first time we've heard testimony from
capitol police officers we've heard
those before
but i think having a hearing that is a
prime time hearing for everyone or at
least the majority of americans to be
aware of to hear
i think is a huge thing especially when
you're talking about
you know donald trump and his party
saying that they are the defenders of
the constitution when really all they
are doing as you said is [ __ ] all
over it they're smearing it and wiping
it on the walls
of the capitol with the constitution
i mean this is the group that says
they're for the first amendment and the
second amendment and they can't name any
other amendment maybe the fifth now
but well it gets hard after the first
one well i mean counting is very hard
right
well they they want to ban math so it
gets it gets right
gabe made a joke there
no one caught it with the the fifth
amendment right i take the fifth so i
was like
a local our local comedian here karen
picked up on his face no because it's
true they know that one because you know
they do well
definitely i mean after eric trump
giving his
deposition of over 500 times saying the
fifth amendment i think they've figured
out what the fifth is maybe i don't know
but well if i could if if i could say i
i thought it was very interesting that
in the introduction which i thought was
really well done by benny thompson
that he mentioned the 14th amendment
right right i thought that was striking
because
he was basically saying
they made this amendment because you
can't be in the government if you are
standing against the government that's
right and they were calling out
people who we have yet to name
that were involved
um
you know there's a lot of that's the
thing about this doj investigation it's
this is not just a as karen said you
know i shot you and here's our crime
this goes in so many directions and it's
so deep and it includes sitting members
of congress you know senators major
military people major people in the
media you know like this is so
widespread that you start here by laying
it out
and then the doj has to go forward so
what they're laying out here is they're
saying
it's it's possible we should be looking
at the 14th amendment why are you a
sitting member of congress if you're
against the government he mentioned that
in his introduction and i thought that
was quite striking
and and lee on that point to have
benny thompson a black representative
from mississippi
talking about the civil war and the
purpose of the amended
uh oath of office to pledge allegiance
to the constitution i mean there was a
certain amount of poignancy there
um i thought benny i mean i've always
been impressed with him all along the
way and every time he's ever given a
press conference or filed papers in in
the in the lawsuits but but tonight
particularly
um i couldn't think of a better
chairperson
to to uh to lead this and to kick off
the uh the presentation absolutely
can you give us one last word and i'll
go to paul for one last word
yeah i i i think that um
the trial or the tri the prosecution i
should say of donald trump
is going to be both something that they
have to build a case which i think
they're building but i think they also
need to
get the get public opinion to support
such a prosecution and joe biden is
somebody who prides himself on being
conciliatory and bringing people
together and like move forward and and
reach across the aisle
and i think he has to unleash
the doj and
allow them to do their job here because
this is what i think this is
what we're seeing and what this hearing
is doing a great job of is not only
laying out the evidence but also
showing why this is so important and why
we can't just move past this one
and reach you know reach across the
aisle and can't we all just get along
it's not it's not going to happen here
and so i think joe biden is going to
have to signal
um
i don't know that this is okay or that
somehow that this is that this is that
this is a good thing to do and i think
the the fact that these hearings are
happening
hopefully will will kind of set the
stage for
for such a uh prosecution but that's
what i hope to see great well you're the
first one that's brought up joe biden's
name so um um
that's the first time that's the first
time in the commentary tonight that it's
been brought up i guess i guess that's
significant when you have one president
trying to overthrow the constitution one
president trying to follow it paul uh
give us your last take here on tonight's
hearings and then going forward what the
what you look for in the future the
future hearings because i want you to
join i want all of you to join me but um
i want you to join me in the future
hearing so what do you look for
well two things one
this has been one of the most
interesting hearings i've ever
i've ever been a part of you guys have
been amazing what y'all brought to this
this has been so different from what you
see on coverage ever everywhere else
um you're going to totally regret giving
me the last word here because i'm going
to say
going in the future you're going to see
liz cheney
cover kevin mccarthy with napalm
burn him down
and then piss on his smouldering ashes
i'm glad i gave you the laughter what
the hell are you talking about he
doesn't know me that well guys i i love
they love the imagery there that's
perfect that is why you saw that
if you remember this will stick out
remember politically speaking though
the blue carpet in kevin mccarthy's
office and his whole staff
running out the door you remember that
got put in there for a reason there is a
reason you saw kevin mccarthy's staff
running she is going to torch him to the
ground well after after his after his
little uh performance on the floor today
i hope she did
everyone thank you thank you very much
for for joining us uh i again come back
for all the other hearings um
stay tuned i got a few announcements
here that i want to make um but
thank you so much for all your
commentary and sticking with us and
watching the hearings with us i really
do appreciate it um thank you very much
guys you guys have a good night
uh so i wanna i wanna give a few
announcements here before we go
again look for all those dates
um
from
midas touch and thank you to the
mizellas brothers and midas dutch for
giving us the opportunity to produce
this
show here for the first january 6
insurrection public hearing
again we will be live streaming every
single one of these now rather it be
during the day or the prime time uh the
final one that is in prime time so be
looking for those dates be looking for
those times
we will be producing just like we did
here today we have our own feed our own
cameras there that are licensed uh two
minus touch will be branded go to the
midas touch youtube channel if you
haven't if you're not there already
subscribe to the channel so that way you
do not miss one of these hearings and
set your reminder we will be tweeting
these out
every time that we run into one and also
while you're at it while you're on
youtube go over and follow our channel
the tony michaels podcast we broadcast
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central for two
full hours
two full hours live
every single weekday monday through
friday also download our podcast on
apple spotify and google
it's been very fun thank you for having
us tonight i know gabe sanchez worked
very hard i want to thank him as well um
for all the production value that he he
brought to the table uh some of the art
you've seen was created while on the fly
here so
everyone go to go to twitter and follow
at i am gabe sanchez and give him a
thumbs up and some fire and some love
over there you can follow tony michael's
pod while you're over there
on the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends don't forget our promo code
tonight is justice at
store.midastouch.com for 10 percent off
all your merch that's justice
at store.midastouch.com
it's been fun until the next hearing
we'll see you soon thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking